hello Marva lights welcome back you are
watching Marvel live at Comic Con 2018
I'm Ryan photograph's a KA agent and I
am I'm so excited to be joined by the
Marvel Studios visual development team
Ryan miner ding Andy Park Charlie when
y'all just came from a big signing right
yeah I was here this morning I got here
like 7:45
we're working but as soon as the doors
opened people rushed they wanted to get
tickets and so there's this new system
for getting tickets for the signings and
so they they hit a plunger and there's a
little thing that spins and it's like if
you don't get a ticket
Bannos has taken your soul there's an
old picture of Thanos but if you do get
it they tell you what signing you get
and the people who were getting tickets
for your guys's signing and they were
screaming and they were just like so
happy and delighted they said this is
Marvel Studios visual development team
and they're just like cool because we
are of course surrounded by the
influences of your work it's very wet I
mean it it's the truth it's just the
truth what you guys have a piece of art
right that you were signing was that
that was the Comic Con giveaway last
year the infinity war posters they had
done they were originally three posters
yeah I was put together into one poster
yeah that was nice yeah so we're 10
years
Marvel Studios movies have what at what
point did you all join the Marvel
Studios team so I started on Iron Man
Jon Favreau hired me on maybe like a
week after Phil Saunders started so
we're like instead of the first artist
working on the cinematic universe we had
Thor Captain America and it was on
Captain America in the middle that we
started the whole team so yeah and you
Andy yeah and then around that time
that's when Ryan and Charlie started the
visual development team and I was the
first one to hired back in 2010 about
eight years ago so Kate pretty much to
start on The Avengers film nice how did
you all know each other was it just like
artists I don't know how artists work
y'all y'all look crazy yeah I literally
like I think you all create magic so how
do you
how did you know each other I had
Charlie had hired me to work on God of
War Charlie started the God of War the
video game you go to war great hair
dandy on as well and so like we were on
God of War
he designed create that's a pretty good
design by the way but that was actually
one of the things of you know once we
had Drax to destroyer
my drawl just dropped like that looks
very familiar
yeah we're all together then and then it
was always just a you know Ryan ended up
going after a very short time and then
he used that Marvel very quickly after
that you know on Iron Man and then after
he invited me and then we that's kind of
how it all started yeah I love how video
games and comics and movies and like
that creative sauce sort of intertwines
and you know you guys jumping you can
jump it's comedians and I mean have you
guys I've done some like comic covers or
comic work to I'm sorry in there um yeah
the first 10 years of my career was
drawing comic books for Rob Liefeld for
Tomb Raider for Marc Silvestri for
Marvel Comics yep something I made the
transition into God or this guy hired me
yeah you guys if you have the itch to do
comics though I always had the edge
never have the time I mean the movie
stuff has been incredibly overwhelming
over the over the past little while I
was looking to do some stuff for
videogames and some I've done some comic
covers from Marvel Comics have you know
kind of come out of the work I've done
for the studios yeah but yeah I'd love
to do yeah I was sitting in Hall H
yesterday for Marvel's spider-man a new
game that's coming out in September and
I was just thinking about all the times
we've been in Hall H for Marvel Studios
and just like the atmosphere what is
that like for you guys who have been you
know as you said working sort of closed
doors you you don't see the Sun you
don't see your families you you know
they
they barely feed you you don't get there
but then you're sitting room with 6000
fans who work literally cry some of them
are crying screaming what does that like
for you yeah I mean I think going to
getting the hall agent seeing that
excitement it's it's one of the best
parts of the job
it's literally maybe the best part like
when I was in there when Tom Hiddleston
came out as Loki and you know that when
the Avengers cast was announced to like
there's there's so much excitement
there's so much palpable emotion in that
room that I don't know those are some of
my best memories of working for Marvel
Studios and seeing that reaction
firsthand yeah I think for me like it
essentially fuels me like it's a
highlight every year to come to
comic-con and especially especially Hall
H I'm so sad when Kevin told us we're
not gonna be doing it this year but um
going into there you know and seeing the
fan reaction it's almost like it fuels
you for the next year but it you know
sustains you to keep on working on these
films and give the fans what they want
to see yeah yeah it really is the reason
we're doing all of this because like I
think we all started off as fans and we
still are fans and so you know getting
to go back and think about why we
originally just fell in love with comics
in the first place you look at the fans
right now and they're like this is what
we're helping to build for them so
definitely do it
you know we're here at comic-con of
course tons of fans and there's
cosplayers and all the stuff is it was
it weird or is it just normal now to see
a fan who is cosplaying as your design
your interpretation of characters that
are now 50 60 years old in many cases
but the ones that you're like what if I
did this and change that yeah it's crazy
it's incredibly cool and it's incredibly
humbling to these characters have been
around and have you know new generations
of fans have come and
and fell in love with him in different
ways and the fact that something that
that we've been able to do for the
studio's that have been part of the
movies could inspire people to wanna
wear the costumes in a like sort of a
new version of the characters or
hopefully is respectful of the
characters as we can possibly be but you
know it's it's it's incredible treat to
see people and I try to stop people and
try to take pictures with them as much
as I can because it's it's really it's
really humbling and gratifying yeah and
just a craftsmanship you know the level
of craftsmanship that these cosplayers
are creating their suits it's just like
oh that looks very similar to the real
thing because we get to you know work
with the real thing yeah it's just like
amazing what they can create now some
sometimes they actually makes you wanna
because they're certain I just got
approached by two low-key cosplayers
that were like oh did you have
back-to-back views my mind is I don't
think I did a back view of that we did
it I only did it for the costume
department but you know there's some
just little sketches so but it does make
you want to actually just create one for
them because they love it so much and
it's really why you're doing it yeah
more so than just to make the movies or
to appease Marvel Studios but it's
really for them in terms of the work
that we do it's really about trying to
make a road map for someone to build the
costume whether that's the costume
departments or what cosplayers it's
actually like there I think it's some in
some cases when like there are not
officially released images like
sometimes I think that concept art is is
what they have to start from it's um
it's incredibly cool to be part of that
yeah you know what that's an interesting
thing I really think about you know when
you're designing these do you keep in
mind sort of the practicality of it or
are you just looking at like this looks
so cool this is what I'm just barreling
to the coolest look whereas they're a
mix what is it when you guys are
thinking about though I mean it's always
a mix it's always depending on if it's
gonna be a real costume we're definitely
thinking about practicality more than if
it's a digital character Iron Man suits
that's where it all started right and
the one of the reasons why that
aesthetic of the MCU started there was
the fact that it felt real and grounded
and that if he raised his arms that the
plates would collapse and so that sort
of realism and groundedness is stuff
that we're always trying to infuse into
the designs and when they're gonna be
costumes I mean if we do something
that's impractical the costume designers
tell us you know and we end up having to
make tweaks and changes and and we're
usually trying to use those types of
limitations as ways of being inspired to
define new solutions and also just push
this far forward as we can we are sort
of responsible for coming up with that
iconic look that people are gonna try
and chase and because it's just a
digital or you know it's a picture it's
easier for us to suggest things that
might be harder than building it
practically but you know we're trying to
do our best to weave it all together and
make the best image that could be
practical as well that's also why
sometimes we do find it necessary to do
something in 3d there's been several you
know instances where it felt like giving
them a image or a painting isn't gonna
be enough and so we actually have to
discover in 3d like you know there's
many cases and there's some specifics
with characters faces like that Thanos
or the Hulk like with Ultron you know
where you have to really figure out is
it going to actually work so those kind
of cases you really do need to just
figure out in 3d and that's all
practical cases - yeah yeah
what about items - you know like the
props and stuff I was thinking about
Russell Bobbitt who's downstairs he's
got his amazing I've been to his prop
warehouse and I was just like well yeah
where am i this is magic place like his
trailer set up and I was like this is
incredible you guys doing that stuff too
and then what's that part of the process
like I mean a lot of it still is like
starting with the classic economic
referencing like what's gonna need it
for the story and then trying to cool it
to create the version of that that works
with the story and it's like as iconic
as possible I mean I think each of us
has got to do a iconic like Marvel item
who did the gauntlet you know honestly I
I think I think Russell was actually in
charge of doing that all the way back
and Thor because it was it's based on
the one that was in Thor and I think I
think he remember the concept artists
name you've had such amazing teams and
so many people across the year sure sure
this was before we actually had our
visit empty so Charlie and I were
working on that film but you know I've
got I've been lucky to have design cap
shield and Charlie did Moliere and Andy
did but even Daredevils billy clubs
enough to do Stormbreaker for infinity
award - I I don't know if I could talk
about whatever I'm looking at those
inside the warehouse and like for the
practicality of those and feeling those
it's the coolest thing in the world
you guys get to actually like well I go
to see my work in threes
living and breathing he's like the metal
storm breaker is incredible well I mean
what we do is as real as we can make it
which is still usually an image on a
computer screen unless we get something
3d printed the stuff that Russell and
the prop masters the prop Department and
especially costume places and the
costume departments have to make let's F
work and all the engineering and amazing
work that they do to make that thing
feel weighted and proper and that it
doesn't like want to tip out of course
and there's hands like it's all
incredible stuff they do as well yeah I
mean I think besides the the weapons
probably one of the ones that we would
be even more kind of on top of as far as
just making sure it comes out a certain
way is like helmets anything that's on
character faces just because both actors
are going to be very specific with how
they don't like certain ways that is
coming out in their face when they're
acting or how how it looks on them
because that's really part of their
persona so that's a huge part like is it
going to come out right and you're
working very closely with the costume
department on that
I think the biggest challenge about the
helmets is you know humans are not like
nine head too tall like a lot of times
we idealize especially in comic books
right so how do you make an actor to
look like the icon with the helmet
without looking like a funcle' bubble
head yeah you know that's a challenge
right you know I've done the ant-man
helmet and the wasp Emmet
Bryan's and like the all the cap helmets
Charlie's done like the Thor helmets the
icons that hundreds of thousands of
people sitting in here right yeah yeah
obviously you're talking about all these
different things that you've worked on
these characters these items is there
something that you know now that we're
in the ten year anniversary as we're
doing a lot of looking back and
celebrating you're going through you
know there's art books there's there's
you know these videos that are out there
things are you like oh man I love this I
remember doing this this really made me
happy you know for me like to work on on
cap and sort of finally getting that
helmet in the stealth helmet to really
fit Chris's head and like really get
that that Captain America silhouette
with the ears exposed like I was really
looking back on that like there's a lot
of things I mean there's a lot of things
like that that was very proud to have
worked on the other thing that's really
amazing is like we got to do these group
ensemble concept art poster pieces that
were you know all of us working on it
and in like the fact that we are a team
we get to work together and and have
been working together for so long and
there's a sort of a man a physical
manifestation of that in that those
posters are like all of our hard work
and it becomes representative of the
film's those are really really those are
the times I look back because they were
they're hard to do like those are those
are late nights those are us like
showing each other what we're working on
trying to match it up and there's a
there's a lot of a lot of passion and
love that went into those